Speaker 1: All right, let's do a lesson here
in dishonesty, propaganda, lying with statistics,
a bunch of other stuff.
I have a graphic that I'm going to show you
that I believe is at least a top contender
for the most dishonest graphic ever shown
on Fox News.
And it's dishonest, probably in three to four
different ways.
OK, here's the graphic.
As you can see, it's from Sean Hannity's Fox
News program last night.
This is really instructive in terms of propaganda
in line with statistics.
The graphic is part of a segment wanting to
blame Joe Biden for COVID deaths.
It was a segment about how bad Joe Biden is.
And of course, the hypocrisy is incredible
because these very same people didn't really
care about the COVID death numbers when Donald
Trump was president that in fact, they went
out of their way to apologize for Trump and
claim he's doing a great job.
And Covid's not that serious and all of that
stuff.
So the claim here is is just comparing COVID
deaths in 2020 to COVID deaths in 2021 and
making it seem that Joe Biden is worse than
Trump.
Now, what the graphic says or shows is that
in 2020, three hundred and fifty two thousand
people died of COVID, whereas in 2020, one.
Three hundred and seventy two thousand people
died of COVID.
So the point here is 2020.
Under Trump, three hundred and fifty two thousand
COVID deaths 2021 not even in the full year
under Biden, more deaths by about 20000.
So let's consider the ways that this is dishonest,
and I'm not doing this to score points for
one team or another.
It's about understanding whether you are being
honestly given information and what you should
deduce from it.
So first of all, Donald Trump was president
the first three weeks of 2021.
During those first three weeks of 2021, about
72000 Americans died of COVID.
So right off the bat, despite this graphic
of these deaths.
Four hundred and 24000 happened when Trump
was president and 300000 happened while Joe
Biden was president.
So like without even debating the merits of
whether this entire exercise makes any sense.
The by President Donald Trump actually was
president during one hundred and twenty four
thousand more COVID deaths than Joe Biden.
This is actually pretty dumb.
I'm not going to even say this is a this is
an intelligent thing to do.
There are lots of people, for example, that
died in February when Biden was president,
but who caught the virus when Trump was president.
Who gets the blame for that death?
It's sort of a weird metric.
It's not very useful, but by the standards
of the people making the graphics, it could
say four hundred and twenty four thousand
dead dead under Trump, 300000 dead under Biden.
That paints a completely different picture.
That's a layer of dishonesty, number one.
Second layer of dishonesty.
The deaths didn't really start in the United
States until April of 2020.
OK.
In the last 10 days of March 2020, we saw
deaths go up.
So even in comparing these numbers and thinking
about them as Trump versus Biden, Trump kind
of had a freebie for January of 2020.
February 2020 March, most of March of 2020.
Now, some will say, David, there were deaths
in those months.
We just didn't know that they were COVID,
yet they were called pneumonia or something
else.
That's the point is they're not in the numbers,
OK?
So in the Biden category there, including
the first three weeks of 2021 when Biden wasn't
even president, plus more months overall since
we have about nine weeks left this year, and
Trump really only had eight months worth of
deaths in 2020.
So that's another level of dishonesty for
what is a very stupid exercise.
All right.
That that's another one.
But now let me get to the really dishonest
part of this.
The deaths, even in 2021, even today, are
mostly overwhelmingly the unvaccinated who
were mostly Trump supporting Republicans.
So is it really Joe Biden's fault that Trump
supporters have been bamboozled into not wanting
the vaccine by other right wingers and they
are dying?
For me, that's the real dishonesty here.
And of course, there's this highly contagious
Delta variant, which plague the planet in
2021.
That's not Trump's fault.
It's not Joe Biden's fault.
Although more vaccination would have slowed
down the mutation, as Vincent Racaniello and
others have told us, so a ton of this stuff,
it's like it's kind of ticky tacky, as we
might say in sports.
Well, there's these three weeks and in January
when when Trump was still president.
But when do the deaths really become under
the watch of one president versus when the
deaths happen when the person got sick?
It's tough.
It's nebulous.
It's not particularly meaningful, comparing
11 months for Biden to eight months for Trump.
That's also dishonest.
But the real dishonesty is that they do all
this stuff while ignoring that the deaths
are higher because of right wing anti-vaxxers.
And it's more right wingers than left wingers
all along who were participating in behaviors
that spread the virus.
And also, this is a subtle attack on vaccination.
We shouldn't ignore that we are far more vaccinated
now than in 2020.
And that was the theme yesterday on Fox News,
in part thanks to the death of Colin Powell,
who, as we already talked about, was fully
vaccinated but 84 years old, immunocompromised
Parkinson's cancer.
So it's incredibly dishonest.
It's important to spot this stuff, and sometimes
there's kind of two analyzes that need to
be done.
One is we just look at the numbers and we
think through, OK, wait, so who was president
in 2020?
How many death?
OK, let's think about that.
When did death start to even be counted in
2020?
We have to think about all of that.
But then there's the big dishonesty, which
is the ways in which these numbers are being
used to make political statements that don't
actually follow from the numbers and ignore
who it is that's keeping people from being
vaccinated in the first place.
So up there, up there?
One of the most dishonest graphics I've seen
on Fox News, when you really break it down
and think it through,